all right everyone let's have a round of
applause for Radovan kabuki so Radovan
is the president and principal data
scientists that the gap data Institute
and more importantly at least for pi
data you are the founder of pi data
Bratislava in Slovakia all right and
today
Radovan is going to be talking about the
data science and data visualization in
python how to harness the power of
python for social good thank you for a
nice introduction
so as for the talk structure first few
minutes it will not be mostly about
python it will be by motivation the I
will try to introduce you why to use the
data science for this purpose for social
good or for the change in society the
second part will be about 20 minutes and
it will be like more technical like
intro to data science in Python and the
rest conclusion so this is like the
basics so more about me as for my like
education background an economist mainly
focuses on finance statistics and what I
have done after the studies I worked
together with the policymakers on
creating reforms so economic reforms
based on data and social like changes
implementation of these changes to
legislature and making it happen I'm
more like MATLAB guy and says guy but I
switch to open-source tools and mostly R
and then Python and also tableau we use
a lot mainly for data visualization so
what we do in give data Institute we
combine the world of data science with
public policy and we are using mostly
open data and we are also
try to like introduce these ideas that
the social changes like the main
problems we now in societies in we have
can be solved on a wave data by
visualizing it analyzing it and making
the right decisions based on them as was
already said by data we found it last
year in Silesia and also like separate
groups for our and also tableau user
group I had the pleasure to work for
this lady in the middle next to Obama
it is our former prime minister so I was
advising her on many reforms this is
this joke underneath is about economics
it is like current state of economies
from crisis to crisis but we learned a
lot from the data and from the failures
so as it is rocket science it really
isn't so what is this about
so right now what media shows us is very
like not the true picture which data
show us what we like are told that we
live in post factual world that all the
fake news and so on also the public
policy is changing the point is policy
is changing like right now in 21st
century we have something like poster of
politics what it's really like the
different picture of what we see and
like Co prefer if you don't know what
cups I say is go Google it it will be
fun so and this guy Hans Rosling you
probably know him his talk like many
years ago it really changed my view on
the
what we should do after seeing his talk
many years ago it really changed my mind
and that is what I would do for the rest
of my life it was like game changer and
main inspiration also for our
organization gave data Institute he
unfortunately left us last year but he's
like messages still living in so how
much open data how many open data sets
are really there in the world this is
like a basic visualization of what is
available currently and we are not using
these that data sets on the full full
amount so there is really huge potential
and not only open data but linked open
data which we can connect these all the
datasets into like a complete one on
which we can like base for example
applications or to see the whole picture
so this and this is like what we are
what I was doing last year it's data is
the founding stone but what we need to
like do is make it like information or
something useful to connect them it is
like linking it together then knowledge
then wisdom and then the policy changes
on the top of it and right from the top
back to basics and then up upwards and
downwards still the still the same so
this is what we're really like need to
do to make the social changes and to
make the data work for us and to make it
all happen
a Python or and also other like tools
for data analysis is really helping like
excel as for data science process how
many data Sciences we have here if you
can like okay so so this will probably
not be many new things for you but this
is like very
useful visualization of this process
from silica it was from data science
away the slide taken and it's really
this is the process in my talk I will
focus only on one part which is the
visualization and exploring
visualization so we start with data
collecting exploring it then clean
transforming it modeling it validate if
it validates deployed and to show people
what is going on or show the
policymakers what is showing what is
going on and then suggest changes and
communicating this is it if it's not
working then all the circle around again
as for the ideas the best way to start
is really like the distribution of
python anaconda as you probably know it
there is one idea included in the
distribution which is spider for me I
really like rodeo if you know this i
really suggest it also for our code also
for python code it's really useful and
it's similar like our studio if you know
so another one which is like currently
very popular is jupiter notebooks you
can also use our kernel or python karen
loader and also julia another so it is
also useful and really a deliverable as
the Python notebook pycharm is also one
of the best ideas for python and wing
wing' is more like hipster way to do
that designs but also people tableau
public is currently really developing
and implementing also our codes it's for
a long time but right now after few
updates ago also implementation of
Python code into tableau visualization
so you can have like the best of both
worlds like data visualization
and really the modeling and machine
learning part of it together in one
package so it's really like useful to
combine the power of Python or in
tableau into like one product or one
visualization one app so this and as for
the Python the best tools I like
separate this circle into this circle
into like four main forming groups and I
like selected that there are many tools
as you probably already know but this is
for me it was really like useful for
example for data collection feather is
the one of the best new formats which
you can use it's a binary file format
file a binary file format and you can
like really easily to switch between if
you have like part of the application a
part of the project do you develop in
one language and you need to like switch
the data to another this is the really
the easiest way how to like use it and
how to combine different code together
and you don't have to like switch it
sometimes CSV is not the best way to go
or you don't have the data in CSV so
this isn't really like very useful if
you have data remotely on Hadoop server
or as a SQL database it's really useful
to use Ibis it works really great with
pandas in Python then parrot X mainly
for parallel reading of CSV and c++
library for data visualization on which
I will detail the focus in the rest of
the speech it's very like Seabourn is
based on not bold lip not all deep is
really not that it's it's the basic one
or the basic library for
data visualization but Seabourn is
really under the highest level if you
want
static visualization so that's the way
if you want something more interactive
or if you want to deploy it on that or
make people exceed your data or your
model is really the best way is bokeh
it's similar like has the all the
advantages of javascript or d3
JavaScript but it's really like a humane
way how to like program or make data
visualization happen so if you don't
know it so far really like use it loudly
is also I will go in detail in for this
library it is more like make your
visualization in a declarative way so it
will take your code from Python and you
can easily switch it to another language
for example to MATLAB or for our and
other languages because it takes also
not just the point but also all the
curves and so on so it will like
recreate your visualization based on
your data in other languages so you can
easily like switch or you can even like
export from other visualization easily
to your project this data if you want
also static a JavaScript like is out
there but if you want to create Maps
really the zero plot lip is the way to
go as for the data cleaning or
transforming your data it is there is
complete package from Randy Olson it's
data cleaner for automatically cleaning
your data and like preparing for your
analyzes so really if you don't know it
you
you should write blaze is based on numpy
and pandas
and it's also one of the best for data
manipulation or data wrangling and for
parallel computing tasks as for modeling
as for me I prefer like statistical
modeling so I don't like use machine
learning a lot for modeling because it's
like black box sometimes like put data
in magic happens and model is really
like useful but I try to like use
machine learning as well as as possible
only in in that case is that the problem
is really unsolvable if there's too much
data to analyze I think it's a dimension
learning or AI should be used as the
last resort
only in the problems that could not be
like used or applied classical statistic
modeling curried but if you want like
stats models is the base library first
is the modeling but if you want to use
machine learning i really suggest that
using Kerris it's the best way as for
the many libraries for machine learning
chaos for deep learning is really the
best one and connectors to tens are flow
from Google and by MCS free is four by
seeing statistical modeling that's it
this is not my slide I took it from one
great speech if you if you are
interested in data visualization like
this year on pike on in in Oregon in
America there was like a note speech and
Jake van der + presented like this
visualization of all the visualization
libraries in Python so as you can
clearly see on this slide it's from his
presentation there are like different
groups of
the data visualization libraries the
main part is based on MATLAB as the like
the first that the visualization first
usable data visualization library for
Python and they are like many pandas is
also has the basics and map portlet
Seabourn network is and so on there are
other groups which are like I have
connectors to JavaScript and you can
like make it interactive so this is like
second part bouquet is really the one of
the most developed and also together
with bottling there are also like
separate groups which are using 3d
graphics or 3d visualization based on
OpenGL technology so a glumpy in case
that you need to visualize this kind of
data and this PI and some other stuff
tools this is really like a useful
visualization about visualizations so
next one this will be like Jupiter
notebook is right now the best way how
to start its formerly ipython and now
it's like combining the power of Giulia
Python and R that's why the name is
Jupiter this like combination of words
and you can easily like use your web
browser to like render all the analyzes
and also other like people can easily
follow your code and you can like make
it interactive you can add visualization
and it's all on the same place so also
for educational purposes or if you want
to like show people how you get the data
from where you get the data how you
analyze them and so on so in one format
you can easily like put it on web and
make it searchable it is
really like tightness data science
platform right now and it's still
improving even for teams if you have
like data science team you probably are
using Jupiter happy to like combine also
the work of your team members so it's
really for collaborative data science
Boca as I already mentioned it's for
interactivity or make your visualization
to stand out on the website mostly you
can easily like all the all the
advantages of JavaScript you can simply
use to like explore your data so it's
also useful to use this tool not only
for deployment or the deployment phase
but also for like exploring you can
easily like play with your data with the
help of this library so if you go to
this side you can easily like on the
gallery part of Boca you can easily like
take all the code and you can like
change few things change labels and so
on so really like use also work of
others to like your project and so on so
this code is free for all and you should
not like start from nothing but there
are a lot of like very useful prepared
visualization only you like add data to
it and it really like work for you there
are bitings also for our but it's
natively Python library
so there are connectors even to Scala go
of the bokor the philosophy behind it is
really to like elegant concise
construction of this visualization and
make it like more people to see and
explore the data and without the
they'd starve or the JavaScript code so
you can also like save it the
visualization into other formats or HTML
documents or even for all of use and
govt s or the other tools which can be
like added the base is Boca but you can
like easily put sliders they're like
selectors and so on so you can like make
dashboard complete dashboard for which
you would like probably need other code
but in this with combination of other
libraries Python libraries you can like
make it happen also in Python this is
the next like visualization library
which is really useful
it's called plotly and that is the
descriptive that I mentioned earlier it
will simply like take all your
visualization and the data that they are
showing you make it into JSON format and
you can easily like use this JSON format
to recreate this visualization into
other languages as you see it's MATLAB
Arbeit and Julia Perl are doing
addressed so it's for this purpose it's
the ultimate library if you really need
this and it also work well with Django
framework so you can easily like make a
website based on the data visualization
and it's great like front-end totally
works as site or has the Java Script
part of it as as for interaction as for
uploading your your code but the new way
how to like create complete dashboard it
was like presented few days ago it's
called - it's one of the products from
plotly
and it's if you know our and shiny
package it's for interactive
interactivity web apps where you can
like present your data visualization in
full so far there was nothing like it or
you should like combine other libraries
together - is the new thing like the
shiny for Python simply so if you like a
half client or somebody who wants to
somebody to whom you wants to present
results of your analysis really do like
interactive dashboards where you can
like show what will change in the model
after I put this selector like on this
way so on
you should look you should use the
dashboard and the dash is really like it
will push your visualization on next
limit so and it's pure Python so if you
don't need to like learn other languages
or the programming languages it's a
really just button and it will like make
the work done in an easy way
so this as for the potential of data
science or what we can do with it the
change so our vision is for the social
change or social good we really believe
that these tools that now focus is
sponsoring that the community is
creating and making it happen it should
be used like the many citizens that is
possible I think that everybody should
be interested in data not just like
computer guy IT guys not just economics
for example statisticians I think that
we should really democratize the like
possibility to learn these things or
learn these tools and really like
analyse lot of data we have a lot of
data as I showed you
in the open data map that we are simply
not using or nobody have touched there
so far so what we really like need to do
is make these tools there are available
but know not many people know about them
so our vision is to like make it work
for democracy for really the society it
could be like the big driver for social
change and for solving really our main
problems in finance in society and
social like part of it for example
health issues for example social
security systems really this could be
the driver open data together with open
data science tools and really like
citizens who are interested in stuff so
not the apathy not the like vision that
there is post truth world we really have
the data like after many many new years
we have like a movement of open
government government is opening on each
level that putting this data from their
servers to us it these data really
belongs to us and should be analyzed by
us because we should be like the drivers
of the change and not like politicians
politicians are for the decisions final
but we should like drive them towards
the decision so this is like our our
vision what we really like need to do is
for example as for migration crisis or
that is like presented for me or from my
point of view it should not be seen as
crisis it is crisis because we are not
prepared for this there will be like a
huge movement of people going to like
Western countries also in the future so
we so far didn't solve the problem but
the
vision of smart cities is really like
necessity so like really the necessity
to like solve all these issues like
smart care to like mmm like urban urban
data science so like use the data
science for projecting of our cities or
for organizations of our cities for
developing our cities so we really like
need this data-driven approach used to
solve this kind of so-called crisis and
many many issues IOT smart retail like
every area of our activities or our
economy is really like under huge
transformation right now and what we are
like living right now is really like the
beginning of age of data and these tools
which we are offered for example in
anaconda and so on we really like need
to harness the power of these tools for
the greater good for the society for the
really for the safe to the humanity
simply so we have to like show these
data make it work for us and really like
to make it work to during the process of
digital transformation this is like the
main main message that you should like
to take from this Beach I really believe
that this future or the future based on
data or data-driven change which we can
like together create it will be huge the
potential is really huge and I think
that we will make it we will simply make
it happen and the future will be awesome
all we have to do right now is to like
start building it start using these data
start like
influence the policymakers to make the
right decision workable for us and to
make like the data really working for us
it's our date generated from our money
this is like about our organization so
we come by like economic research public
policy and bigger science and our motto
all the like information if you want
slides from this speech it will be in
tiny cc-by data
berlin and also on github so thank you
for your thank you for your attention
and in case that you have any question I
will be here also after this session so
and you can also like contact me here
and on via Twitter so thank you for your
like attention and
[Applause]
okay thank you very much for the fun we
have time for a few questions any
questions from the audience I might have
a bit of a question so you mentioned the
the we're gonna have these these smart
cities in the future what role do you
see for sort of automatic systems to
control these cities so for example like
self-driving cars that are driving
around or four grams all smart retail
where you can track what happens in a
shop or how many people go into a shop
or what people are interested in I think
that first of all it will be not much
technical problem right now we have all
the tools we need for this and also AI
which could like use this data and make
it work for us but what will be you it
will be a legislature if you like - as
for this data about our like movement in
the city this will be like make it
happen - for us to like solve the
legislature issue how these or which
data should be allowed to share and
which are not able to share it will all
be in an app anonymized but there is
possibility to extract from this data
even more information that we will be
willing to share so it's really like
there is a huge potential but also a
huge risk for like using this data for
bad purposes what we have failed to do
is really like make it the smart way
it's not just smart person the smart but
we should be smart to like make it
happen smartly because it can really be
there is a huge potential but it can be
like a huge disaster if it's done in a
bad way so I say that it's not a
technical issue right now it will happen
in few years but there will be like
other problems that we need to solve
first or before it
and it's really the smart cities is not
about the technology it's about our like
services the new services which can like
be create from this data we can really
understand ourselves better thanks to
this but this attitude is really
necessary because the urbanization is
really like developing a lot and people
are moving from place to place so we
need to like make it happen but we
should have to like make it in a smart
way so the basics are the smart people
which will be implementing it so after
this we can make it thank you any more
questions from the audience
in this case let's thank the speaker
once again
[Applause]